Eli Roth's highly anticipated
Thanksgiving horror film offers us a
fresh take on slasher movies without
sacrificing even an ounce of nostalgia
Eli has always wanted to make a horror
movie like scream or Halloween and this
is it it's a who done it campy horrific
take on a holiday that's rarely been
touched by the slasher genre can the
residents of Plymouth Massachusetts
survive the holidays without being
carved like a Thanksgiving turkey it's
it's always been Eli's dream to make a
movie that emulates the vibe of scream
or Halloween something that's incredibly
scary that's also fun with fantastic
kills it makes sense as those movies
have created some of the most desirable
Aesthetics when it comes to slashers and
that's exactly what Thanksgiving is
trying to go for every time one of the
characters meets their end there's a
major desire behind the aesthetic to
make it look like something from one of
the classics we try to truly make it a
classic kill we take it very seriously
it's a badge of honor for us every
character's demise is going to be truly
epic there was a ton of thought and
preparation put into the gore so that
when you're watching it will feel eerily
similar to the iconic slasher scenes we
know and love here's Johnny don't worry
I've got more on the gore later
something else I really love about this
movie is there truly is no shortage for
Camp the production team even made a
bunch of fake trailers to hone in on
this campy slasher Vibe now the trailers
were mostly for the production crew to
mess around and have fun emulating
classic horror tropes in a comedic way
we're going to do fake trailers and we'd
like you to Direct One and I thought oh
my God this is the coolest thing ever
there is an iconic shot of a parade
scene in the Czech Republic that was
repurposed into small town America even
though it very much still looked like
the Czech Republic that's the beauty of
grind houses even if it looks like
you're shooting in the sh Republic it
still works cuz it's supposed to have
kind of a low budget feel to it a lot of
the campia scenes involved Jordan lad a
good friend of Eli which was intentional
one of the great things is Jordan and I
know each other so well that I can
really really just push the envelope
with her not to State the obvious here
but the plot was heavily inspired by
classic slasher movies one of these
guessing who the Killer is something
that's incredibly scary kind of like a
who D it Vibe like scream does but it
was also important for Eli that they
also cover something no horror movie
ever has Thanksgiving there's been
horror movies for literally every
holiday Christmas Valentine's Day
Halloween obviously but nothing for
Thanksgiving unless you count thanks
killing but that was the big driving
force behind the idea the movie starts
with a Black Friday not ending in a
tragedy honestly not that far off from
reality that causes a rise of a
mysterious Thanksgiving inspired killer
they start brutally picking off
residents of Plymouth massach etts the
birthplace of Thanksgiving one by one
what seemingly starts off as random
slashings soon becomes very clearly
motivated by some deep horrific Revenge
plan get excited so the gore is
definitely going to be uh gory but it's
not going to have you throwing up in the
aisles looking at you terrifier 2 Eli
Roth describes Thanksgiving more in the
vein of cabin fever or hostile as in yes
it's rated R but he still wants it to
appeal to the mainstream audience he
wants to completely outdo every horror
scene he created in the fake trailer so
basically yeah it's going to be gory but
you should be all right if you're a
horror regular Eli goes into a bit of
detail in an interview with collider I
want everyone screaming and going oh my
God I can't believe they did that it's
that kind of movie but it's also not
going to be in the way you'd expect we
come into this world in a very violent
way and we go out in a very violent way
so the real question I had about this
movie is why did it take 15 years years
to make after dropping the fake trailers
well apparently they've been trying for
quite a while in fact like most
Productions in the recent past they were
held up for a while by the pandemic but
they also wanted to make sure the script
was actually worth shooting before they
even thought about going into production
we were trying to get the script right
for years I was just connecting the dots
between the trailer and then I was like
am I just filming the scenes in between
what I already did before Jeff renle
Eli's co-writer on the film pretended
that Thanksgiving 1980 exists and that
it was so offensive that every print was
destroyed and the only thing that
survived was the trailer basically he
had to pretend that the only thing that
existed about this movie was the trailer
every copy of the script was burned and
it was treated like a reboot and yeah
here we are we've waited 15 years for
Thanksgiving to finally Grace our
screens and we couldn't be more excited
the gore the camp and a nostalgic take
on a fresh story line have everything
going for it to create a major holiday
classic now what are you most excited to
see